you got jake paul he said he'd put up 10
million if if elon put up to 6 million
oh damn do you do you think that uh jake
paul uh mike tyson is going to fight
larry paul uh larry paul and larry paul
mary paul and larry paul's dad
is that the dad no but did i forget the
dad's name is that fight happening that
tyson looking by bit happens in february
if i have to guess
that's uh and what what's going to
happen with that i yeah with tyson like
we don't know the rules like greg paul
uh with tyson went on the road like his
thing against roy jones i'm sure you're
into it like you know it's so historic
but with roy jones like that that was
like a sp is like an expert
yeah yeah so with i would assume with
logan same thing like mike's not gonna
try and take his head off why not he's
55. it's not what he does he like
logan's not going to sign the fight if
he can get his head taken off yeah but
but what is 55 years
25 logan paul starts coming after tyson
head hunting you don't think
stupid he didn't do it against floyd did
he he didn't try ripping floyd's head
off i feel like he was trying no what
about what about jake and tyron what was
the breakdown of that
uh is that a real fight that was a real
fight yeah see i i view him two
different kind of fighters like jake's
actually going for a career he's making
steps to get to the real professional
levels
logan's like how can i make the most
he's jumping over steps to get to the
real professional levels what do you
mean he's he's
jumping over steps to get to the real
professional level like fighting you
know tyron woodley um so so for instance
so if let's say you want to be a boss
nate nate robertson well sure but when
you're not a real fighter yet he hasn't
fought an actual boxer his age
yet well tommy fury's two years younger
than him we're gonna see seven
professional boxers they're gonna do it
yeah in december and jake and tim out
then what
well i don't know tommy fury's a
background as a fighter his brother's
obviously his stepbrother
brother same dad half brother same dad
okay well i'm just saying but he comes
from you know he comes he's around all
right great okay that's i'm just saying
any 7-0 as a pro pro boxer 7-0 i got i
got tired
i got tommy
yeah all right is it going to be fixed
no
no five hundred dollars all right i want
my money in cash or i come i beat your
ass
dude i come and beat that ass
yeah and then if i have to pay i'ma just
beat it just just because all right cool
man what do you do with an open hand
smack them up about the face and ears
like well the last time i did it tell
them how what happened the last time i
did you never hit me you killed them
because what happened last time because
i get worried
i worry about roughing up with your
lungs you got the black lungs and you've
done no work in a gold mine listen
[Laughter]
i'll tell you what after this just grab
them just grab them by just get under
hooks on them and see what happens but
do you want to i mean i've seen you look
oh
i [ __ ] him up this ain't no like i do
it for the instagram like oh like the
little guy like you know like
but just grab him and just
i'll let you get any position you want
on him any position you want and then
and then we've already been through this
i just whatever you want though i'll
give you a headlock we'll put them in
headlock you can hold them there and see
what happens yeah okay